you've said recently that
um the Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
may go down in history as the man who
destroys Israel can you explain what you
mean by that
yes I mean he is basically tearing apart
the social contract that held this
country together for 75 years he's
destroying the foundations of Israeli
democracy
you know I don't want to go too deep
unless you want to because I guess most
of our listeners they have bigger issues
on their minds than the fate of some
small country in the Middle East but for
those who want to understand what's
happening in Israel there is really just
one question to ask what limits the
power of the government
in the United States for instance
there are a lot of checks and balances
that limit the power of the government
um you have the Supreme Court you have
the Senate you have the House of
Representative you have the president uh
you have the Constitution you have 50
states each state with its own
Constitution and Supreme Court and uh uh
Congress and Governor if somebody wants
to pass a dangerous legislation say in
the house it will have to go through so
many obstacles like if you want to pass
a law in the United States taking away
voting rights from Jews or from Muslims
or from African Americans even if it
passes even if it has a majority in the
House of Representatives it is a very
very very small chance of becoming the
law of the country because it will have
to pass again through the Senate through
the president through the Supreme Court
and all the federal structure
in Israel we have just a single check on
the power of the government and that's
the Supreme Court
there is really no difference between
the government and the legislature
because whoever there is there are no
separate elections like in the U.S if
you win majority in the knesset in the
parliament you appoint the government
that's very simple and if you have 61
members of knesset who vote let's say on
a low to take away voting rights from
Arab citizens of Israel there is a
single check that can prevent it from
from becoming the law of the land and
that's a Supreme Court
and now the Nathaniel government is
trying to neutralize or take over the
Supreme Court and they've already
prepared a long list of laws they
already talk about it
what will happen the moment that this
last check on the power is gone
they are openly trying to gain unlimited
power
and they openly talk about it that once
they have it then they will take away
the rights of Arabs of LGBT people of
women of secular Jews and this is why
you have hundreds of thousands of people
in the streets you have aeroforce Pilots
saying we we are stop we stop Flying
this is unheard of in Israel I mean we
are still living under existential
threat
from Iran from other enemies and in the
middle of this you have Air Force pilots
who dedicated their lives to protecting
the country and they are saying that's
it if this government doesn't stop what
it is doing we stop Flying
so as you said uh I just did the
interview and as we were doing the
interview there's protests in the
streets do you think the protests will
have an effect
I I hope so very much I I'm going to
many of these protests I I hope they
will have an effect uh if we fail this
is the end of Israeli democracy probably
uh this will have repercussions far
beyond the borders of Israel Israel is a
nuclear power Israel is uh uh has one of
the most advanced cyber capable
capabilities in the world able to strike
basically anywhere in the world
uh if this country becomes a
fundamentalist and militarist
dictatorship
it can set fire to the entire Middle
East it can have this stabilizing
effects long uh far beyond
the the borders of of Israel so you
think without the check on power it's
possible that the Netanyahu government
holds on the power nobody tries to gain
unlimited power just for nothing
I mean you have so many problems in
Israel again Netanyahu talks so much
about Iran and the Palestinians and
Hezbollah we have an economic crisis why
is it so urgent at this moment in the
face of such a position why is it so
crucial for them
to neutralize the Supreme Court they are
just doing it for the fun of it no they
know what they are doing they are they
are adamant we are not sure of it before
there was a like a couple of months ago
they came out with this plan to take
over the Supreme Court to have all these
laws and there are hundreds of thousands
people in the streets again soldiers
saying they will stop serving a general
strike in the economy and they stopped
and they started a process of
negotiations
uh to try and reach a settlement
and then they broke down they they they
stopped the negotiations and they
restarted this process of our
legislation trying to gain unlimited
power
so any doubt we had before okay maybe
they changed their purposes no it's now
very clear they are 100 focused on
gaining absolute power
they are not trying a different tactic
previously they took they had all these
dozens of laws that they wanted to pass
very quickly within a month or two
they realize no this is there is too
much opposition so now they're doing
what is known as salami tactics slice by
slice now they're trying to one low if
this succeeds then they'll pass the next
one and the next one and the next one
this is why we are now at a very crucial
moment and when you see again hundreds
of thousands of people in the streets
almost every day when you seem
resistance within the Armed Forces
within the security forces you see high
tech companies saying we will go on
strike you know it's our private
businesses
hide the companies that's I think it's
almost unprecedented for private
business to go on strike because what do
we what will uh economic success benefit
us if we live under a Messianic
dictatorship and again the fuel for this
whole thing is to a large extent coming
from Messianic religious groups
um which just the thought what happens
if these people have unlimited control
of new of Israel's nuclear Arsenal and
Israel's military capabilities and cyber
capabilities this is very very scary not
just for the citizens of Israel it
should be scary from for people
everywhere so it's it would be scary for
it to uh go from being a problem of
security and protecting the piece to
becoming a religious War it is already
becoming a religious warming the war the
conflict with the Palestinians was for
many years and National conflict in
essence over the last
a few years maybe a decade or two it is
morphing into a religious conflict which
is again a very worrying development
when nations are in Conflict you can
reach them compromise okay you have this
bit of land we have this bit of land but
when it becomes a religious conflict
between fundamentalists between
Messianic people compromise is becomes
much more difficult because you don't
compromise on eternity
you don't compromise on God
uh and and this is where we are heading
right now
so I know you said it's a small nation
somewhere in the Middle East
but it also happens to be the epicenter
of one of the longest running one of the
most tense conflicts and crises in human
history so at the very least it serves
as a study of how conflict can be
resolved so what are the biggest
obstacles to you
uh to achieving peace in this part of
the world
motivation I think it's easy to achieve
peace if you have the motivation on
wealth on both sides unfortunately the
present uh juncture there is not enough
motivation on either side either the
Palestinian or Israeli studying peace
you know in mathematics you have
problems without Solutions you can prove
mathematically that this mathematical
problem has no solution
in politics there is no such thing all
problems have Solutions if you have the
motivation
and but motivation is the big problem
and again we can go into the reasons why
but the fact is that on neither side is
there enough motivation if there was
motivation the solution would have been
easy is there an important distinction
to draw between the people on the street
and the leaders
in power in terms of motivation so
are most people
uh motivated and hoping for peace and
the leaders are motivated and
incentivized to continue War I don't
think so or the people also I think it's
it's a deep problem it's also the people
it's not just the leaders is it even a
human problem of literally hate in
people's heart yeah there is a lot of
hate one of the things that happened in
Israel over the last
um 10 years or so Israel became much
stronger than it was before largely
thanks to technological development
and it feels that it no longer needs to
compromise
that and this is the many reasons for it
but some of them are technological uh
being one of the leading
powers in cyber in AI in in high tech
we have developed very sophisticated
ways to more easily control the
Palestinian population
in the early 2000s it seemed that it is
becoming impossible to control millions
of people against the will it took too
much power it spilled too much blood on
both sides
uh so there was an impression oh this is
becoming untenable
and there are several reasons why it
changed but one of them was new
technology Israel developed very
sophisticated surveillance technology
that has made it much easier
for Israeli Security Forces to control
2.5 million Palestinians in the West
Bank against their will
uh with a lot less effort less boots on
the ground also less blood
and uh Israel is also now exporting this
technology to many other regimes around
the world
um again I heard Netanyahu speaking
about all the wonderful things that
Israel is exporting to the world and
it's true we are exporting some nice
things
water systems and and to make new kinds
of tomatoes we are also exporting a lot
of weapons and especially uh
surveillance systems sometimes to
unsavory regimes in order to control
their populations
can you comment on um I think you've
mentioned that the current state of
affairs is the de facto three class
State can you describe what you mean by
that yes for many years the kind of
kind of the israeli-palestinian conflict
is the two-state solution can you
describe what that means by the way yes
two states
um within between the Jordan River and
the Mediterranean will have two states
uh Israeli Israel is a predominantly
Jewish State and Palestine as a
predominantly Palestinian state
uh again into a lot of discussions where
the Border passes what happens with
security Arrangement and whatever but
this was the big solution Israel is
basically abandoned the two-state
solution maybe they don't say so
officially the people in power but in
terms of how they actually what they do
on the ground they abandoned it now they
are effectively promoting the three
class uh solution which means there is
just one country and one government and
one power between the Mediterranean and
the Jordan River but you have three
classes of people living there you have
Jews who enjoy full rights all the
rights uh you have some Arabs who are
Israeli citizens and have some rights
and then you have the other Arabs the
third class who have basically no civil
rights and limited human rights and that
that's again nobody would openly speak
about it
but effectively this is the reality on
the ground already so there's many and
I'll speak with them Palestinians who
characterize this as a de facto one
state apartheid
is it do you agree with this I would
take issue with the term apartheid
generally speaking as a historian I I
don't really like historical analogies
because there are always differences key
differences the biggest difference
between the situation here and the
situation in South Africa in the time of
the apartheid is that
um the black South Africans did not deny
the existence of South Africa and did
not call for the destruction of South
Africa they had a very simple uh
um goal they had a very simple demand uh
we want to be equal citizens of this
country that's it
and the apartheid regime was no you
can't be equal citizens now in Israel in
Israel Palestine it's different the
Palestinians many of them don't
recognize the existence of Israel don't
are not willing to to recognize it and
they don't demand to be citizens of
Israel
they demand
um some of them to destroy it and
replace it with a Palestinian State some
of them demand a separate state but uh
you know if the Palestinians would adopt
the same policy
as the black South Africans if you have
the Palestinians coming and saying okay
forget about it we don't want to destroy
Israel we don't know a Palestinian
country we have a very simple request
very simple demand give us our full
rights we also want to vote to the
knesset we also want to get the full
protection of the law that's it that's
our only demand Israel will be in deep
deep trouble at that moment
uh but we are not there
I wonder if there will ever be a future
when such a thing happens where
everybody the majority of people
um Arab and Jew Israeli and Palestinian
accept the one-state solution and say we
want equal rights
Never Say Never in history uh it's not
coming anytime soon from either side
when you look at the long term of
historian
one of the curious things you've seen
and that's what makes us different human
groups from animal species you know
gorillas and chimpanzees they are
separate species they can never merge
cats and dogs will never merge but
different National and religious groups
in history even when they hate each
other surprisingly they sometimes End by
merging if you look at Germany for
instance so for centuries you had
prussians and bavarians and Saxons who
fault each other ferociously and hated
each other and they are sometimes also
of different religions Catholics
Protestants you know the worst war in
European history according to some
measures was not the second world war or
the first world war it was the 30 Years
War which largely on German soil between
Germans Protestants and Catholics but
eventually they United to form a single
country you saw the same thing I don't
know in Britain English and Scots for
centuries hated and fought each other
ferociously eventually coming together
maybe they'll break up again I don't
know
but the power of of the kind of forces
of merger in history you are very often
influenced by the people you fight by
the people you even hate more than by
almost anybody else